Speaker 1: Welcome back to the show.
Let's go back and hear from a few more people
via discord.
You can join the discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
Let's go to Pablo from Albuquerque, New Mexico.
Welcome, Pablo.
Pablo from Albuquerque.
Welcome.
Please unmute.
Configure your microphone, Your Honor.
Speaker 3: There we go.
There you go.
Speaker 1: You can hear me now.
I can.
Speaker 3: All right, great.
So the last time that I called in, you mentioned
that you hadn't been to New Mexico before.
And it's unfortunate because right now we
actually have some really exciting stuff.
You know, I don't know if you heard if we're
making higher education free for people that
enrolled in six and six credit courses and
then, you know, we just legalized marijuana,
cannabis.
And my question is sort of tied in with that.
Health care.
Obviously, that's one thing that we've tried
and haven't been able to make much progress
with.
Do you think that a better way of trying to
get a universal health care plan would be
also to go the exact same way along with like
cannabis legalization, meaning?
Mm hmm.
Just having a Democrat or a state saying,
if you're from here, you'll get free health
care, you'll get universal health care.
And then if you are from one of these other
states that also.
Supports universal health care.
You will have insurance covered through these
states.
Speaker 1: So the details are a bit murky
the way you lay them out.
But here's how I could see something like
this.
Working states start to set up their own single
payer plans.
Vermont tried to do it and it failed.
But it was a good idea.
Some state does it.
Okay, great.
Then a second state does it.
Those states could have an agreement for sort
of a consortium of sorts where now there is
a two state single payer system.
The only part of this that I've not yet figured
out is what happens if tons of people who
work in other states move to those states
just for the health care?
You've got to make sure that you're capturing
their taxes.
And there are ways where I mean, listen, if
you have if you work from home for a big corporation
and you move from Texas to Arizona for Arizona,
single payer, in theory, you now live in Arizona.
You should pay taxes in Arizona.
But for a lot of smaller businesses and entrepreneurs,
you can live in one place but kind of maintain
residency in another and not pay taxes where
you're living.
So that would have to be figured out.
But I love the idea of starting single payer
or something like it at the state level and
as states do it, they can work as a consortium
to expand the risk pool.
I think it's a beautiful idea.
Speaker 3: Again, the reason that I brought
up the university, a higher university, it's
the way that they're also they're saying if
you've resided in New Mexico for at least
12 months, then you're allowed to get there
and, you know, free or subsidized health care.
Right.
And so but, yeah, as you say, for smaller
places, it'd be a lot harder to do, I suppose.
Yeah, but I think that's about it.
Oh, there was one other thing I can't remember.
Speaker 1: All right, well, let's save it
for next time.
Pablo from Albuquerque, thank you for the
call.
Very important issue